that moment when the officers kneeling
on him and he's saying I can't breathe
and you see the look in the officers
eyes and the thing I kept going back to
is like this [ __ ] thinks he's
gonna get away he thinks there's no
repercussions for this I'm Taylor rooks
and these are conversations about
defining one's relationship to blackness
and how that defines their America so JJ
all of these begin with the same
question so my question for you is when
did you realize that being white was
different from being black it's a it's
an interesting question for sure so I
have to provide a little bit of
background
I'm the middle of five kids we growing
up we lived out in the sticks
my parents were or like hippies I mean
they lived sort of an alternative
lifestyle we were in Cookeville
Tennessee for a while they had like a
farm that we lived on 11 acres in
outside Charlottesville Virginia then we
moved to Roanoke where I grew up and I
was home-schooled
and so in fifth grade I started going to
public school in that same year I also
started playing AAU basketball with the
city team the Ronald Jaguars and we had
like probably 75% black players and 25%
white players it was a nice sort of mix
of guys from that time on I knew it was
different because I would have
conversations with my friends on the
team that were black and I'd have
conversations my friends on the team
they were white and it was a medial
apparent apparent to me that black
people are treated differently in this
country the guys would talk about their
on so their parents or their living
situations or when it was like at school
what it was like to go to the mall you
know I'm having these conversations all
throughout elementary school now junior
high school and then you know I went to
Bowie Williams when I was 14 I played
with the seventeen-year-old group for
three years he's like an AAU legend so I
would drive
half hours across the state and Duke
practices and tournaments with them and
I think that was those three years was
really what like solidified sort of you
know my belief system on race in America
because I had you know we traveled all
the work all over the world at this team
and I just had these amazing and candid
and open conversations with guys about
race and what it's like so when you said
you guys would have conversations like
with your white teammates versus your
black teammates what was it that stick
at like when the Black team was to talk
about going to the mall how was that
experience different from when the white
team is to talk about going well it
wasn't even just the conversations I
experienced it with them you know I can
I can go I went to a County public
school I can go to the mall as a 13 year
old or a 14 year old adolescent with two
or three white friends and then I can go
to the same mall with my a you teammates
and how we're treated in the stores
differently how we're looked at us
differently
when we would stop it restaurants on the
road and a u-turn it's like how we're
looked at you can you can sense it you
can feel it so I again I think they the
the thing that I like continued
throughout my adult life and again I've
been very fortunate basketball has given
me a lot of opportunity and has expanded
my worldview in a lot of different ways
but especially on race and I've been
able to have these conversations now for
then she's almost 26 years these are
conversations that I've had and these
are the conversations that I've been
able to have in a room with a couple
white teammates and a couple of black
teammates all at the same time so we've
been having conversations about this for
a long time so in a time like now
because I've been very interested in how
black people experience this versus how
white people experience this when you're
on your phone and you're scrolling on
Twitter and you see a video of a black
man being murdered by the police yeah
walk me through your reaction from the
moment you see the video to the moment
you kind of calm down and sing the video
I'm gonna make this personal
so I'm not gonna make a broad
generalization about what white people
see versus what black persons but I'll
make it what I see so I have what's
called empathy I have what's called
compassion so I can't watch that video
through the lens of a black person
because I'm not a black person but I can
try at least or or or or you know you
know try to comprehend what that would
be like it's horrific it's emotional
it's raw it's miserable it makes you
sick to your stomach when you see what
happened to George Floyd
you know I again that first week
especially when the emotions were so raw
you know I cried multiple times and it
seemed like every time you went on
Twitter every time you turn on the news
you know it's it's that moment when the
officers kneeling on him and he's saying
I can't breathe and you see the look in
the officers eyes and the thing I kept
going back to is like this [ __ ]
thinks he's gonna get away with it he
thinks there's no repercussions for this
and look if we're talking about
specifically about police brutality I
think there is a culture where there is
an accountability I think that's been
shown time and time and time again where
officers have mistreated and sometimes
murdered black Americans and there
hasn't been any consequences there has
not been any consequences and that's the
look on his face I know there's not a
consequence to this there's a smirk to
it
there's this there's this notion of I'm
more powerful than you and that that
makes you sick it makes you sick that's
not how it should be that's not the
world I want to be in that's not the
society that I want to raise my children
in so yeah it's it's it's it's emotional
it's emotional for anybody and and you
know obviously I've talked to a lot of
people over the last few weeks and I've
talked to a lot of people from a lot of
different races it's emotional for
everyone um and again I just go back to
like trying to view it through the lens
of a black American and what that must
be like and it's difficult to comprehend
but it just makes you sick I want to
talk about those emotions because
everything you said I absolutely agree
with so for me as I go through this the
emotions that I feel are hurt
disposable insignificant kind of cast
aside frustrated sick tired and those
are all emotions because when I look at
the video I see myself what are the
exact emotions the words that you feel
when you see those videos because I just
wonder I agree with you that it is
impossible for a white person to fully
feel that it's it will never be possible
yeah but so is it sadness is it guilt is
it like what are the things that you see
cuz I I want to understand it's a great
it's a great question I actually have a
follow-up question to you about what you
just described so so first of all for me
sadness for sure guilt for sure I don't
want to call it white guilt but I will
say it's guilt and I'll tell you why
because I feel like if if I'm in a
society where that is allowed to happen
in broad daylight where there's a modern
day lynching in broad daylight then what
is supposed to be a progressive city in
this country and I'm not doing enough
that's where the guilt for me is I'm not
doing enough I haven't done enough the
people I know
that have an influence and have a voice
they haven't done enough the over the
overriding emotion for me was anger and
so I wanted to ask you about this
because I think the anger for me and the
anger for a black person is two
different things yeah no I think it's
such a deep-rooted anger for black
people because it's the kind of anger
that is always there because it feels
like nothing at all is changing and
realizing at some points that you feel
like you aren't in control of your life
more importantly you're not going to be
in control of your death and what the
consequences of that death probably
won't be and I always think of there's
this book and it's God on earth we're
briefly gorgeous and the author in it he
talks about hummingbirds and he says
looking at a hummingbird moving so
quickly but staying in the same place I
think that's a black people feel like
like a bunch of hummingbirds that are
having to do so much but they're not
moving and they're screaming so loud but
no one is listening I mean I have been
anger angry to the point that has driven
me to like hate I don't mean obviously I
don't mean hate I like you what I mean
me the person I see in that video think
something bad should happen to that
person that video for hurting this
person who didn't deserve it
yes so like there has to be a word that
is deeper than anger right you know and
I think it's also scary sometimes
because I know that a lot of black
people also feel incredibly numb to this
I have watched so many people that could
have been my friend died on my phone
like normal day scrolling and then
they're shot and they're dead and
they're not ever gonna come back yeah
and it could have really been anybody it
could have been any of us this not being
able to do this simplest thing is it's
so yeah it's anger but it like it's
feared to because the world because
America has created this system where
this white person is going to be more
powerful than me and that's fear so I
feel scared when I watch the videos and
I and I feel very angry when I watch the
videos
so you mentioned the word like numb and
so I think what is really sad to me is
the notion that a black person can be so
angry at that video
well while simultaneously feeling such a
sense of despair numbness
cold-heartedness because you just
described they feel like a hummingbird
moving a million miles an hour in place
and that is that's right that's sad
that's really sad to me that's hard for
me to sort of reconcile it really is
yeah no I think absolutely and it's and
it's hard to there has to be a there
needs to be you would hope in a
progressive society you would hope that
there could be a way to use that anger
in a positive way right so it's like I'm
angry that emotion when it subsides
turns into a sense of despair a sense of
numbness a sense of cold-heartedness and
where have we gotten we've gotten the
same place that we just were agreed now
and I think so I saw this tweet and it
was from a man named Wayne Reed and he
said white supremacy won't die until
white people see it as a white issue
they need to solve rather than a black
issue they need to empathize with no
doubt and I do think a lot of white
people are feeling like well I feel sad
for you I'm empathizing I'm seeing you
and like that's the role that I play and
really the role that white you'll play
is dismantling the entire thing to be
great and everybody has to feel that way
for there to be apps like any movement
at all you know the talking about it
isn't the work you know actively seeing
it in your life and fixing it is the
work and I also don't think listening is
the work I think it's important to
listen but it isn't enough to be like I
want to hear you it's like figure out
the thing is that you can do
independently the things that you can do
with your family when you go home to try
to change this trend that has been here
for ever so I think yet people's roles
are very different and the burden isn't
on me oppressed it's on the oppressor
and you just that's I think it's very
important to always make that
distinction but I do know I would say
this is a super nuanced and complex
conversation we talk about family how do
you or have you or are you going to
speak to your kids about race it's a
great question so I just want to go back
to what you said just second it yeah so
so first of all you are absolutely
correct in that the system was created
by white people and it's going to be
have to be white people the dismantling
system I agree with you I think when you
mentioned like listening is not the
action I would just say to white people
specifically it's part of the action
because if you don't know what the
conversation is about and you can't help
and you've seen again and again where
there's been some well-intentioned
well-meaning white people who genuinely
I think are good people who want to help
but they've been a little tone deaf
because they're not listening to what
the conversation is about and in the
second part of listening to me is
acknowledged so it's it's listening and
then acknowledging and then we can start
taking action because we need to know we
meaning white people we need to know
exactly what we're trying to solve here
because not all of us created the system
I'm not saying I'm not to blame what I'm
saying is I'm not the I didn't vote for
all the policy people I you know the the
the systemic racism but it's been around
since slavery ended obviously in slavery
for 250 years was even worse than
systemic racism but I said yeah white
it's not that white people are the
problem it's that racism no no no I
agree like it's not white people that
are issue racism is the issue and the
only thing I say I have a problem with
listening
I agree listening absolutely is a
partnership but I think sometimes people
equate listening and hearing it isn't
enough to sit down and just like listen
to the black person
it's then translating that into your
everyday life so it's like what
actionable item are you gonna take from
the listening is why I'm like it doesn't
just stop with listening lips me
listening is important because listening
is step one and then you know what sub-2
and sub-3 and so for is where I think
that change comes but you're absolutely
right you have to listen to figure out
what's next yeah but a lot of attention
has to be put on put out what's next for
sure so the family question that you
just asked so I already have and not
just in the last three weeks I've
already had these conversations with my
kids we already talked about these
things you know especially with the
older one who is fairly precocious and
and sort of gets things and is always
had sort of a good understanding is very
observational you know even with you
know it was a it was a hard day the day
after the George Floyd video he came out
cuz his parents you don't want your kids
to see that well my son my oldest he's
getting ready turn six he saw it and
yeah and we we watched we let them watch
cartoons in the morning they watch a
cartoon show while they had breakfast
and at like 7:30 8 o'clock we put on the
Today Show and so the video was on it
was just on and he's in the room still
so he says he said mama I don't
understand why that police officer
killed that man
why did he kill that man police officers
are good you know please officer good
that's that's his worldview based on
whatever television I'm I don't talk
about police officers whatever
television he watches whatever it is
that's his worldview police officer good
good guys there's good guys and bad guys
and everything he watches good guys bad
guys so having to explain to him that
not all police officers are good that
police officer are inherently meant to
protect people and inherently meant to
serve people but that doesn't isn't
always the case and to try to explain it
to
six-year-old is not the easiest thing in
the world you know I'm just gonna be
candid with you about the idea of
teaching your kids about race so racism
isn't itself as a learned behavior right
so I think a lot of people say like I'm
colorblind
but that's not an actual thing like
we're human beings we make distinctions
and create categories it's from an
evolutionary standpoint we've always
done this this is not like a new thing
so the conversation that I have is is
you know I would be very frank with you
to a five-year-old here's what I tell my
five-year-old you treat everyone the
same no matter what they look like no
matter what they talk like no matter how
they move and no matter how they treat
you you treat everybody the same and you
know we had a chance during mmm the
first few weeks of quarantine when they
were still in school we were
homeschooling every day so we would do a
word of the week and the first the first
word that we learned was respect and we
went through every day we went through
the different meanings of what it meant
to respect you know in a very small way
you respect your parents respect your
family members respect your brother
maybe treat your brother with respect
how does that look right then it was how
do you treat other people with respect
obviously there's only so much you can
treat teacher five and three but these
are things we're already doing I you
know I'm a Christian I subscribe to this
guy Richard Rohr he's an incredible
incredible thinker credible philosopher
he's a Franciscan priest he works at
this at the center out in New Mexico and
his worldview is the same worldview that
I have and is the same worldview that
Jesus had and it's the same worldview
that I want my kids to have which is
basically you love everybody and you
love God and everything else stems from
that that's a very simplified version
and obviously the world is way more
complicated than that
but if that's your building block and
that's your foundation then it's really
hard I think to to allow sort of those
there's even evilness to creep in for
sure and and you're right you know I I
can't imagine how you would frame that
to somebody that is five you know
there's not so much debated right sure
but obviously I think I think reflected
in your life as you got older you were
taught that in order to teach someone
about respect you also have to teach
them about black and white yes and how
those things are related so how did your
parents do that to you or teach that to
you or how did you learn yourself if it
wasn't from your parents
no I it was for my parents look we grew
up in I would consider where we grew up
the South you know if you live in
Virginia yeah then you live in the DC
area you're not from the south okay I'm
not from the deep south but I am from
the south southern Virginia Tennessee
like it's the south and obviously some
of these these these thought processes
are embedded in the culture you know I
we used to go down to North Carolina for
Au tournaments or when I would drive
down from Roanoke to Duke you had to
pass through this this town in in
Franklin County which was the County
directly south of Roanoke there's this
little town called Boone's Mill and it
was known for two things it was a speed
trap and number two on the side of the
road there were all these like antique
you know knick-knack goods stores with
Confederate flags everywhere so you were
reminded of that evilness again evilness
you're reminded of that every time you
drove through the town so even though we
were from the south my parents you know
they grew up in the north one front one
in Ohio one in Connecticut met at
college so they had a different
worldview than a lot of people where I
was raised and so you know again we were
we were just talked to love all people
to you know treat people with respect
I've had these conversations what my
best friend in the world is a mix of
like four different races okay so yeah
we have wheat we have these
conversations all the time
I told him the other day I'm like you
know growing up in my household like you
didn't make jokes about race or religion
you didn't make jokes about gay people
my parents did not raise us that way as
an adult that that all those things are
so inappropriate
they've always been inappropriate to me
they're so inappropriate to me going
back to my kids like my kids will never
hear me say those things now I'm not
doing this to toot my own horn
what I'm saying is in some households
that is loud and that permeates into a
mindset of race right these people above
these people
gays are here straighter here trans are
here whatever it may be it's a status
yes exactly
and my parents didn't raise me that way
they didn't raise me at all
and frankly like they allowed me you
know to go play with the city team they
allowed me in high school to drive for
and I cried for enough hours across the
state to play with Boo Williams and give
me these opportunities there was never
any hesitation there it was just you
know you you want to be around the best
people that's that's what it came down
to so how do you define racism because
and we've talked about this a couple of
times on the series it's a some people
think racism means pointing to the black
person say I don't like you because
you're black hmm that's one very
specific type of racism and I think one
could argue that's probably the least
threatening type of racism it's the
racism that manifests itself and the
thing is that we don't see in the
systems that we live in every day
including the police that are the worst
so what is racism to you and also how
have you seen maybe white people you
know I could will around you exhibit
these racist behaviors
I think racism it's a hard question to
answer without a dictionary in front of
you first of all
now the racism
to me is just believing that because of
your skin color you are superior to a
person of a different skin color I think
that's a very broad stroke there but it
can you know capsulate a bunch of
different feelings a bunch of different
real-world sort of things the other
thing I would say because my background
in cultural anthropology so it goes our
anthropology you know there's this
there's this notion of the other and the
other can be a bunch of different things
but in general and culture the other is
essentially something that you see as a
threat and I think you know goes back to
something I read the other day with
Richard Brewer where he was talking
about the ego lies to us and they think
that if someone if someone this group of
people that they want something that I
have they want equal rights they want
equal protection they want equal
opportunity well somehow that's gonna
take away from for my rights and my
opportunity when that's just not really
how it works the pie is big enough for
all of us so I think I think going along
with that sort of thinking of
superiority there's also an underlying
perception of threat yeah and I think
what you're saying is true I also think
the truth of the matter is one of the
reasons racism still exists is because
white people do recognize that they have
benefited from that system so it's
almost I don't want to use the word
beneficial for racism to exist for white
people but it has been beneficial for
racism to exist because when you put it
down to its base level right if there
have been so many movements so any
people fighting for equal rights for so
many years yet it still exists it's
because people feel as though it's
necessary for things to continue to
operate in the way that they do I I
totally agree with that I think I think
the group in power will always want to
hold on to that power
mm-hmm and and sometimes that can be
done in a very subtle way and sometimes
that can be done in a very explicit way
so if you you know if you go back to you
know the the war on crime the war on
drugs you go back to Bill Clinton's
crime bill in the 90s like these were
all at the time now we kind of at least
for me I didn't perceive that as a
ten-year-old when Clinton signed that
bill in 94 but at the time I thought he
was like oh let's put the bad guys in
jail right at the time you know it was
it was maybe not as explicit as it seems
now and now it seems pretty explicit but
it was a warm life yeah yeah absolutely
agree maybe Taylor can I ask you a
question absolutely so just not not book
definition but to you what it what is
your what is your definition of racism I
think racism is a structure a structure
that puts one person in power in one
person not in power for me that's racism
is when a white person is in power and
uses that power to keep black people not
in power and I don't mean power in the
huge term
I mean agency I mean the power to just
be you the power to do things you want
to do every day so yeah so anytime that
a white person's power threatens my
existence that's racism yeah the same
way I think anytime a person a white
person's white privilege threatens my
agency that's racism whether they are
actively participating in that racism or
not it's that racism is so ingrained and
everything that I'm experiencing the
racism even though you might not feel
like you're doing something that is
racist because the thing we're living in
creates that environment does that make
sense for sure you mentioned you
mentioned agency by the way and I've
I've said this I've said this publicly
before but for some reason every time I
say it like people freak out but like so
Kevin Durant in 2016 when he joined the
Warriors LeBron
he makes the decision there's always the
group of sports fans who want to make
the argument I took the easy way out you
know he went and joined Dwyane Wade and
Chris Bosh in Miami he went and joined a
team that had just beat him in the
playoffs like what I'm not gonna use any
explicit is you know but you know what
I'm saying
there was that there's that notion but I
think an underlying I really believe
this an underlying reason for the sort
of the reaction to Kevin and LeBron
making those decisions it's because
people were uncomfortable with powerful
black men making a decision for
themselves I really believe that and I
that goes back to systemic racism in our
society lately
again it goes back to what I was saying
- it's about the threat the perception
of a threat well the perception wait a
minute this guy he's he's behind a
system how dare he he's bucking the
system he's bucking the system and I
think I'm sorry no I was just gonna say
a you know I when Kevin did that in 2016
and this is one of my podcast was on
Yahoo I did a whole episode on this I
mean no episode I just [ __ ] love the
decision I love we did now I was on the
Clippers at the time we were trying to
beat the worse so I was like yeah we're
in trouble but uh but I you know I loved
I loved him taking ownership of that
agency and just saying nom I'm gonna do
what I want to do yeah and I think that
really speaks in a lot of ways to sports
in general which is it's a lot of black
people making decisions and a lot of
white people telling them why that
decision maybe was right or wrong frame
that way which is a lot of what it is I
you know one thing that I think is great
about both of those guys with LeBron and
Kevin is that they have done obviously a
lot of things on the basketball court
but they have also done so many things
for black people for people in general
and business etc etc two things with
that though is I hate the black people
feel as though
they have to be this excellent being in
order to be considered good right and I
think that a lot of black I think a lot
of black people experience that the need
to be the best in order to justify your
existence because why people simply do
not have to do that I think it's great
the black people do it I just hate that
we feel like we have to that's a B
there's always this perceived idea that
you know if you're rich you can beat
racism if you're educated you can beat
racism if you look this way you can beat
racism that all of these things will be
able to be your armor to stop white
people from not liking you simply
because you're black I would argue and
this is the case probably for LeBron and
Kevin that being all three of those
things in a lot of ways makes you a
target mm-hmm because it goes back to
what you talked about with the threat or
feeling like why does this person have
this when I don't
so while sometimes these conversations
happen and may be famous or more wealthy
black people who frame like they have it
easy it's important to understand how
racism still exists for the Kevin Durant
and the LeBron James and every black
person who is doing something in the
public eye because it's absolutely still
there it's just showing itself in in a
different way
you know what's showing itself and the
people that want to burn to come in to
ranch Jersey because he made a decision
to make his life better
it's a the first thing you said is
because it's pretty profound actually
about about goodness and and measuring
up to white people's goodness as if that
somehow absolves you from racism I mean
and that's the fact that maybe some
people think like that and some people
feel the need to do that it's it's
incredibly sad but it's just I think it
speaks of all you because it's true what
you said it speaks volumes to how shitty
our society is in that regard yeah he
does like is it's not it's not it's it
it's not authentic at all
the whole system should be in place yeah
it feels like your value isn't you being
a human your value is in like the things
that you can do mhm and I just don't
think I think that's a very toxic way
that sometimes that people have to live
that you have to have things that like
like I said justify this space that you
take up and the sad and it's more than
it being sad it's exhausting you know do
i I always got to be the best you know I
always got to be waiter than everybody
else in this room just for you to think
that I belong in the room right but yeah
it is a part of it I want to end with
this which is the same question that I
asked everybody at the end which is that
words mean different things to different
people how do you define America so I'm
reading this book right now how do you
know you're gonna so it's written by
Colin Woodard it was written a few years
ago this is actually a follow-up to a
book that was written back in the 70s I
think it was called not the nine
American nations Colin calls his book
American Nations and he argues that
basically there's 11 nations in our
country so with that as sort of the
foundation I think the easiest way to
define America is messy
the reason it's messy is for a lot of
reasons but there are so many competing
ideologies there's so many competing
agendas and America because of its
history of slavery and systemic
oppression especially of obviously of
black people we can never really we can
never really be clean even
we ever reconciled that we could never
be clean America is always going to be
messy
now the Constitution I think has done a
good enough job to keep our society
running but when you have someone like
Trump in office who has empowered even
further empowered some racist ideology
and white nationalism it makes things
really messy and at times it feels
untenable at times this society this
country feels untenable like we're on
the brink I assume I'm talking about
everybody white people black Hill
everybody
I assume that we've all felt this way
before whether that was you know in the
late 60s World War two obviously during
the Civil War but if you look it's funny
because if you look at all the times
that our society and our country has
really been at odds it's been centered
around race so that's and that's my
definite messy messy America's messy and
a lot of it is is race and yeah you said
something true you're like you know so
many things have happened I don't know
if it ever be completely not messy but I
hope that everybody can do their part to
just clean it up as much as as much as
possible for sure yeah look we need to
do a better job we as in sort of our
generation we need to do a better job of
participating in all elections and I
just want to give you some credit
because you recently voted in Georgia
yeah in the primaries right yes just
wanted to say thanks for doing that
you know I'm I've voted in the national
election since 2004 and in some state
elections but I have never been
consistent with local elections and so
this is going forward this is sort of
one of
you know touchpoints for me about how
can i be better right and so that's one
of them and the other thing is you know
what's really interesting that's
happening right now like we have so far
to go Taylor you and I could agree we
have so far to go but for me I'm trying
to be an optimist and I'm trying to be
an optimist it's been three weeks or so
it's in three weeks or so since since
George Floyd was murdered and ER we're
already seeing action we're already
seeing some action you know we've seen
local police departments already and
local governments already enact some of
these changes that we've been asking for
with with no chokeholds DeBlasio comes
out he says we're gonna we're gonna
reallocate some funds from the NYPD to
other areas so things are happening I
think people are finally sort of
listening for anybody who's listening
this we have to continue we have to keep
yes we know I like this is not going to
be something that just lasts during the
summer or something it just lasts during
kovat you know this is something that's
got it's got to be you know years
possibly generations to make it we have
got to do this I want to end with one
thing and I'm sorry to be long-winded
the first few days after
after George Floyd was murdered you know
I again I referred it referred to it
earlier as a modern day lynching in
broad daylight with the guy knowing a
camera was on them so two of my heroes
growing up we're not you know when I was
at Duke where Tommy Smith and John
Carlos and I wrote to like 30 page
papers on these guys I had the
opportunity last last fall the pelicans
brought in Tommy and Edwin Moses who was
another you know hero amazing athlete
political active one seeing the iconic
photo two black men fists up at the
Olympics that is who day day is
referring to me wins the gold medal he
sets the world record in the 200 meter
Olympic Games in Mexico City in 1968
John Carlos wins the bronze and they had
agreed upon doing a couple things so you
know they they did the the black power
this stuff John actually forgot his
gloves so Tommy gave him so John put up
his left hand so there was a couple
things that they were protesting it but
so Tommy's up there with no shoes on and
he's protesting against the poverty and
the in the black community
John John Carlos has a as this like
necklace or chain around his neck and he
was he was protesting the lynching of
black people that was in 1968 I was 52
years ago not that long not that long
right not that long ago like it that was
yesterday 52 years later we all get to
witness we all had to witness I should
say we all witnessed a black man being
lynched for the same thing that he was
protesting 52 years ago so we can make
an argument right Civil Rights Act it
gets signed into law in 1964 we can make
an argument that things are marginally
marginally better for black people in
America but I'm 35 if I say in 52 years
that things are marginally better than
they were 52 years ago for black people
in America
and I feel and we've all failed we must
and I and I would encourage there's a
lot of really great articles about the
white allied [ __ ] moment between all
three like there's very long form
articles about that that I encourage
everyone to read and you're right it's
just crazy that yes that was so long ago
but it's even wild that we were dealing
with like my mom was born yeah at that
time you know so but you're right I
think it's gonna take an accumulation of
moments like that and people wanting to
work together in that way for anything
to be better
you were you were so thoughtful and you
offered so many great insights so I'm
I'm so thankful to you for doing this
coming on well thanks for asking me to
do this I appreciate it so thank you
[Music]